uh inside the nba comes your way
next oh sorry he said
this is sweet and if the blazers won
game one
go on to sweep the lakers
another infamous charles guerrero team
oh no it's like it's not a sweep is it
it's not a sweep
oh this
that was chuck realizing hey i get to
use the broom when we start inside the
nba
uh all i can remember was with mark
jackson oakley
oh yeah yeah booming philly with y'all
yeah i feel
i still hate mark jackson for that oh
it's funny inside the nba
comes your way next not the props chuck
thank you sir kelly oh that's funny
that was funny you caught me on that one
the end of a quadruple header night here
on tnt and it ends here's a little
nugget for you
the last time the number one seed in the
east and the west
both lost their opener in the first
round was 2003 when the spurs and the
pistons
both lost their opener
yeah that's exactly like chuck you all
got the same bodies too you and her
he's about to be in suffolk what do you
mean about today
really you're right not about to be
uh doesn't seem old yeah
you're right nobody said he was crazy we
said he was
a little touched hey i met james brown
one time
we had him in the street i wasn't here
then he wasn't here
yeah he came in and he came in and sang
he was performing in vegas one time and
i went to meet him i went to the room he
had a smoking jacket all that everything
yeah he came in
he sang in the back this is when we were
in the old building and that's oh that's
right
he wasn't here yet yeah james was chuck
did he know who he was oh yeah
what does that mean he's trying
enough about enough about all that let's
get to the highlights
of this uh what a way to finish off the
night
man alive uh so lebron and the lakers
dame dalla and the blazers the one
eight match-up damian lillard with the
lay
look look i'm gonna tell you and then
this
they score easily and they they didn't
even play
great tonight that's awesome they didn't
play good did they kenny
they they played good they didn't play
great they did please
double double in the first quarter 10
points and 10 rebounds
and the fact that they're not scared of
the lakers
not scared at all i don't think they'd
be scared anybody with those five guys i
don't know what i'm saying
portland by 16 early and then the lakers
jose again
superman he's not superman he's a man
he played well you got to stop filing
because you know even though when he get
those files he put them in the penalty
they just they just playing oh man yeah
i think he'll shoot that falling for
later very well
miller the 34 point night i love that i
love the way he played tonight
under control he was fantastic
great pass inside to anthony davis who
in the first half had 21
and seven it was 57-56 portland
at the half i'll tell you what man we
still we're still doing an awful job on
the offense on the defensive board they
got to clean that up and the turnover
what's this wee wee wee come on i told
you i'm on the portland block yeah yeah
he should say we now i'm telling y'all
oh
davis again blaze with fans
except there's one lead on the front row
she got me fine 25 thousand dollars for
cussing out
and i like the rest of the but ernie
honestly i'll let you guys
kenny you saw a white side there and
then bang bang
kyle kuzma who had 14 and 8.
again watch kuzma here take it strong to
the hole
84-78 lakers this was a big play right
here
they were down six at that point that
was big hey steph
how do you like that three steps 36 feet
i think you could shoot as deep as him
step
i gotta see it when you come back i love
the way hey take that skill
bayless game tied at 89. here comes the
bronze
swatted by whiteside i hope y'all heard
me america skip billy
take that with your punk ass this was
the 36 footer the other one was just 30
feet no i can't stand him
alone no i don't like him nobody he
wasn't he's no way around the building
92-89 give me that carmelo
huge three 95-89 but
not over yet here come the lakers in
transition these guys are so reckless
with the ball
man so now you got a 95-93 game oh give
me that trent
barry trent jr
oh good pass nurkic on kuzma
you can't leave the corner can't leave
that kid you can't leave you look out
you got to
take protect the bastard portland
trailblazers
over the lakers 100 to 93.
lillard with his 34 mccullum 21 nurkic
16 and 15. lebron james
with a triple double the 24th in his
postseason career
magic has 30 that's the only guy with
more 23
17 and 16. well he better catch him in
the next three games
the most exercise charles has gotten in
years
who is that turbo from breaking is that
it oh man that's a good movie from the
past
that ain't the movie but that's a good
uh
neither team shot 40 percent in this
game portland 39 percent the lakers 35
portland wins it and uh who who just
gave you that big
me why because
you say anthony davis had 21 points in
the first half
yes he did and finished with 28 and 11.
that's not good enough
he averages 26 during the regular season
in order to be effective in the playoffs
aka dominant you got to add six to eight
points
that's always been the formula i need
him
to be aggressive in score every time
don't just stand out there and pick and
pop you know we always talk about
porzingis even porzingis is in the same
category for me
so for you to have 21 points in the
first half and only end up with 28.
that ain't good enough a regular person
gonna be like oh 28 16 is pretty good
but no not to great player standards if
you want to be good you know we talk
about this with joel and b
you want to be good you know 28 is good
chuck don't know what he talked about
that's why he ain't got none of them
bangs
i got four and kenny got two i need him
to average 34-35
yeah okay that's right i'm gonna let you
respond because
yeah okay that's right you got to step
up ethan davis played pretty good
no pretty good ain't good enough hey
lebron played good
they got to get some help can uh
kentavious pope had one more point than
i did
and on oh for nine shooting and so
listen underdog has gave me a stat
this is the fewest points that blazers
have had in a win
all season long they didn't play good
tonight they only shot 38 percent
the reason i picked the blazers to win
this series the lakers only got two guys
who are going to be consistent
there's anthony davis and lebron and
they're emotional
no no no no but what the point i was
making was
they have to play great every great
superstar
remember when i was talking let's play
the choir game every grace let's play
the choir game for a second
oh every girl get the [ __ ] jordan
no he didn't kenny help me out i'm going
i'm ready
she was jealous okay i had to play great
for kenny to get open cut it out chuck
listen stop it if you look at the game
lebron and ad play well
but if you look at the trailblazers dame
can have a bad game
cj can have a bad game carmelo can have
a bad game
nurtures can have a bad game that's the
difference in these two teams in my
opinion
lebron he's the point forward
he had 15 assists tonight like he
he said he set a record tonight that's
never been done before
i don't think he can do that four times
against his team well he's got to do
four times and win uh yes
yes and this and this was a loss but i
don't think he can do that four times
and win that's just my personal opinion
you know
two years ago not like not last year
rather not this year last year
uh charles and i were like the portland
trailblazers are gonna do
and then nurtures got hurt collins
garrett this was what we had
foreseen this type of team now
the lakers are still the lakers i i
wouldn't go overboard to where
i wouldn't grab brooms no uh you know
but
this is you also have to think they're
possibly third best player in in the in
the near future zach collins didn't even
play tonight
and they they score
as we said so easily so when this team
is scoring that easily
what you have to do is you have to limit
the possessions and if you don't limit
the possessions
you have the offensive rebound which
means you need more possessions
than lakers didn't either they didn't
limit their possessions
or they didn't get more possessions so
no matter what lebron does or what a.d
does they're going to lose games like
this
because they have like this i'm saying
like this
but if they limit their possessions or
they get more offensive rebounds that's
how memphis stayed in them
that's how brooklyn almost beat him with
carous levert
because they just got more and the
lakers have better players
you know at their elite level but to
negate what you're saying
if the two stars that have to play well
like chuck and sam they dominate
none of us none of that stuff matters do
you think that lebron dominated tonight
no he did not
he played well but playing willing i
said lebron dominic i didn't think a.d
played you can't have 21 points in the
first half and have seven points a
second
it wasn't even a 21 points it was eight
for 24. he wasn't efficient
so when the guy's not efficient then
you're not there's no domination like
okay here's the mental i was a double
down guy meaning
i'm the guy on defense who's gonna go
double the guy who gets hot
like so if somebody gets hot i'm gonna
go double there's no urgency for me to
go double a guy who has 24
who's shooting eight for 24. so then i'm
not coming as fast which now doesn't
leave this guy this is what you're
talking about
doesn't leave the shooters open as
easily because there's no urgency for me
to go
he's not killing he's scoring but he's
not killing him
i'm gonna let chucky brown i'm gonna let
pete chill cut i'm gonna go see i'm
gonna let those guys i was playing with
i'm gonna see if they can guard him for
a second and
but if he starts killing i'm coming
early he dominated the first half
between
listen 21 points in the first half is
not easy to do
but it's two halves you gotta do it the
second half this uh this game had a lot
of a high
high profile eyeballs on it as we uh as
we check social media
uh steph curry yeah thank you stephen
thank you chef thank you steph
tucker had to see baby my favorite
player like
[Music]
steph came at me tonight all right
oh hey a great beer russell love you
bill no doubt no doubt love you bill
you're right and he followed me gave it
to shaq back in the day
oh my god